in political discourse every term has
two meanings you got to start by
recognizing that so democracy has an
official meaning which is something like
you know the ability of the public to
take part and running their own affairs
or something but also has a technical
meaning the one that's actually used
something is democracy if it's run by
the business classes if business runs it
especially business elements they're
supportive of US interests then it's
democracy if not it's not a democracy it
doesn't matter
nothing else matters virtually you'll
check you'll notice that this criterion
works quite perfectly for identifying
democracy same is true of the term peace
process it has a dictionary meaning in
the dictionary meaning a peace process
is some kind of process that's trying to
lead towards peace but it also has a
technical meaning the technical meaning
in its technical meaning it refers to
whatever the United States happens to be
advocating at a particular moment
wherever diplomatic initiatives the
United States is advocating that's the
peace process notice it follows that
it's a logical impossibility for the
United States to be opposed to the peace
process
that's a nice consequence you to prove
that the United States is for peace you
don't have to do any laborious inquiry
into the Annoying facts because it's
true by definition since the peace
process is whatever the United States is
up to the United States is always
supporting peace and the u.s. enemies
are always opposed to peace because
they're not supporting what the US is up
to and by definition that means they're
opposed to peace you'll never find in
the US media or for that matter in us
scholarship for the most part any such
phrase as the United States is opposing
the peace process or the United States
is trying to block the peace process you
can't find such statements because
they'd be logical contradictions
actually I made this statement and a
talk in Seattle a couple of months ago
and there is a media analysis group in
the Graduate School there and a couple
weeks later I got a letter from somebody
saying he was kind of intrigued so he
did a data based study of the New York
Times over 10 years and he found out
like 900 references the peace process
and check them all out and in fact
there's not one case
where the United States was opposed to
the peace process pretty remarkable
because that was a period when the
United States was trying to undermine
the diplomatic negotiations and
settlement in Central America and in the
Middle East and so on notice that's
pretty remarkable even the most sublime
state you'd expect that it wouldn't
always be in favor of the peace process
maybe just by error or misunderstanding
but in the case of the United States
it's a hundred I suspect it's a hundred
percent you might check and see if you
can find any exception and the reason is
it's just true by definition since the
priests process is whatever we do now
there are two major examples of peace
processes in process now one of them's
in the Middle East and ones in Central
America has no time to go through the
details but if you look you'll notice
that in the Middle East the United
States has been trying to block a
diplomatic settlement for the path of
the arab-israeli conflict for the past
twenty years and it's still trying to
block it and in this is virtually
isolated in the world opinion that's
exactly what's going on now if you like
I'll give you some details I have a
detailed discussion of it in the current
issue of Z Magazine if you're interested
but I think it's quite clear
nevertheless the discussion is the
United States is trying to advance the
peace process there's another peace
process going on in Central America
which is no less interesting read you
from the front page of The New York
Times today the lead story in The New
York Times today which I picked up on
the airplane says US envoy urges
Hondurans to let the Contras stay ok let
them stay in Honduras the track you come
out and then comes a long story and you
turn to the second page the continuation
page and it says on its face the
administration proposal to keep the
Contras in place would seem to be
inconsistent with the spirit of the
regional peace agreement which calls for
their relocation but administration
officials say there's no inconsistency
well that's about as close as you can
come you know on its face it seems to be
inconsistent with the spirit of the
peace agreement well the peace agreement
is quite explicit the 1987 peace
agreement which the United States has
succeeded in undermining and destroying
says explicitly that the one
indispensable element in obtaining peace
in the region is the end of any form of
support logistical military
propagandistic etc for irregular forces
like the countries now it's not it
doesn't seem to be inconsistent with the
spirit but it's flatly inconsistent with
the words to keep the Contras in pray
place well the same is true of
everything else about that the there was
a there's that was the 1987 peace
agreement which the United States tried
to undermine and did undermine with the
support of the media but there others
there's a right now there's debate going
on on so-called humanitarian aid to the
Contras well the term humanitarian aid
has a meaning in fact the World Court
and its decision defines humanitarian
aid it lookup paragraph 243 of the world
court decision and it defines
humanitarian aid as aid given for the
hallowed purposes of the Red Cross
namely to relieve human suffering and
crucially it says aid that is given
without discrimination to civilians on
all sides of any conflict only under
such conditions that anything qualifies
humanitarian aid
well that means all the stuff given is
called humanitarian aid has nothing to
do with humanitarian aid its military
aid but you'll never find this discussed
in the media I doubt if you find one
reference to this in the media so now
we're talking about humanitarian aid
that's going to be voted Bush
administration hopes to keep the Contras
in place in violation of the 1987
agreement well it was also a central
american presidents agreement just last
month and that said something too it
said the Contras have to be relocated
away from honduras so this is flatly
inconsistent with that not the spirit
but the wording furthermore there was a
ceasefire agreement between Nicaragua
and the Contras last March over the deep
objections of the United States last
March 23rd and that ceasefire agreement
has some very specific terms in it it
says that a
can continue to go to the Contras in
ceasefire zones all of which are in
Nicaragua when provided by a neutral
agency that's what the wording of the
agreements is Congress passed
legislation right after that sent to
send what they call humanitarian aid to
the Contras but if you look at the
legislation it says specifically that it
must be in accord with the ceasefire
agreement and it must be an accord to
the Central American Peace Agreement
well that means that the only aid that
Congress could legally send to the
Contras in accordance with its own
legislation is aid given by a neutral
agency like the Red Cross to Contras in
ceasefire zones inside Nicaragua that's
not just my interpretation the ceasefire
agreement also specified an
international official in charge of
monitoring the agreement it's a
Secretary General of the Organization of
American States he wrote a letter to
President Secretary of State George
Shultz stating that the aid that the
United States was sending was
inconsistent with the ceasefire
agreement and he was wanted to call the
attention of the Secretary of State to
this serious violation of the ceasefire
agreement and the Congressional
legislation
I was never reported Congress proceeded
to send the aid the neutral agency that
they selected was US aid State
Department subsidiary that's the US
that's the neutral agency and they're
sending it illegally to Honduras in fact
the aid that they're sending is not only
in can flatly inconsistent with the
Central American peace agreement it's
even inconsistent with Congress's own
legislation that's pretty tricky
you'll never find one word of discussion
about this this is against the
background of years of the United States
trying to undermine every effort at
political settlement of that of those
conflicts whether they were through the
contador a group of Latin American
democracies or the United Nations or the
Security Council where the United States
vetoed resolutions calling on all states
to support international law and so on
and it continues but nevertheless
according to the media the press the
United States government is supporting
the peace process well
I'm suggesting that wherever you look if
you look closely you'll find exactly the
same thing you'll find quite a
remarkable degree of civility and
subordination to establish power
particularly remarkable because there's
no force behind the there's no authority
that can impose force this is willing
subservience not compelled subservience
and the kind that in fact flows I think
just from the the logic of the
institutions for the reasons that I
mentioned well let me return finally to
a prediction of the propaganda model
that I mentioned already namely that
however well confirmed it is it cannot
be part of the discussion it's going to
remain outside the spectrum of debate
and respectable circles maybe with some
very marginal exceptions the reasons are
the ones I mentioned they're pretty
obvious that conclusion again is quite
well-established empirically and I think
we may assume with fair degree of
confidence that that will continue to be
the case